[Musik]
wer diesen mann so unauffällig durch
zürich schlendern sieht könnte ihn glatt
für einen äußerst durchschnittlichen
schweizer halten doch freddy burger geht
bei den großen ein und aus weil er
selber zu den größten seines fachs zählt
für die bürger ist einer der
erfolgreichsten unternehmer in der
unterhaltungsbranche
[Musik]
er ist der manager von udo jürgens dem
mann der mehr als 1000 lieder komponiert
und über 100 millionen tonträger
verkauft hat sehen wir sind jetzt gerade
punkt angekommen ich hab gerade
informiert dass du jetzt noch bei
interviews fast hektischer tag aber ich
freue mich dass endlich weil du im
mittelpunkt
wir sehen hier um gestanden haben rum
geguckt wenn du hier so das ist ja
unheimlich es längst nicht alles
natürlich
[Musik]
freddy burger bespricht mit udo jürgens
details zur laufenden tournee ein
prozedere das die beiden seit 35 jahren
kennen
seit bürger udos manager wurde am anfang
der erfolgreichen zusammenarbeit stand
eine begegnung mit ottos vater rudolf
das war ein schneiden geschichte ich
glaube ich so gerade eine hand gehen
werden
und da hat zu dir gesagt der hat über
das wenn derzeit klavier setzt berührt
er den menschen aber versteht nichts vom
geld der hat keine ahnung wenn es mit
dem jetzt 50 in der hand geben dann geht
er los und freut sich des lebens und
dann kommt dann aus und hat nichts mehr
also sie können nicht von ihm erwarten
dass er sehr geschickt mit diesen dingen
umgeht
er braucht nicht viel aber versteht
nichts davon
also lassen sie ihn das machen was er
kann und betrügen sie ihn nicht
sozusagen mein vater sowieso nie wieder
war angesagt bringe sieht all das in
ordnung was bei ihm nicht in ordnung
müssen dass da ist eine menge nicht in
ordnung
jetzt steuert schulden gehabt ich habe
ich habe mich um nichts gekümmert
da musste ich natürlich in probleme
laufen schnell stellte sich heraus dass
der schweizer der ideale manager für udo
jürgens ist dass die zwei sich perfekt
ergänzen und er kann mit mit menschen
die etwas nah am wald sind sind es
wieder früh wieder wiederbeginn hatte
ich eher kann es mit solchen leuten
umgehen also es nicht einer das sofort
verzweifelt wenn er mit einem musiker
der vollkommen anders tickt zusammen
kommt zu einer er weiß dass in diesem
chaos denn was wir empfinden und das
durcheinander und die leichtlebigkeit
die wir haben
da rebellin hat genauso wie ich das
darin unsere kreativität licht es gehört
zu den verdiensten von freddy burger
dass er sich stets aus den
künstlerischen fragen heraus gehalten
und sich um die berechenbaren faktoren
gekümmert habt
die schweiz kennengelernt natürlich und
wie lässt natürlich dass ich bin ja
nicht aus der welt herumgereist auch in
viele fremde länder und weit weg und
atlantik und weil sie überall und ich
habe ihn wirklich glücklich nur gesehen
wenn eine swissair maschine gesehen also
das modell das rote kreuz hinten nur auf
dem das weiße kreuze roten grund sind
auf dem flügel dann wusste er jetzt
langsam ist die welt wieder forderung
aus der erfolgreichen geschäftsbeziehung
sagen beide sei längst eine
männerfreundschaft geworden
mehr als zwei dutzend firmen gehören zum
unternehmen dass freddy burger
management heißt sein unterhaltungs
imperium managed künstler veranstaltet
konzerte und events und betreibt
restaurants und nachtclubs über 120
millionen franken setzt seine firma
heute um 350 angestellte arbeiten für
ihn
in fast fünf jahrzehnten hat er
unzählige stars getroffen und
kennengelernt und sich stets daran
erinnert dass seine mutter erika großen
wert auf anstand und manieren gelegt
hatte
stand 5 sterne lügt betrügt nicht
unbedingt ehrlich trotzdem war es für
die eltern eine mittlere überraschung
als freddy burger mit 19 jahren seinen
beruf als hochbauzeichner aufgabe und
musikmanager wurde
so fällt macht du hast du zahlst ob
jetzt groß geisterhand dubios wunsch und
du kannst du ausgang nun die stets
erhöht
wenn der gemachte manfred die bürger
heute nach schwamendingen zurückkehrt
dann fährt er vorbei am theater 11 und
im hallenstadion an den stätten seiner
triumphe doch nie vergisst er dass er
nur wenige meter entfernt an der
walliseller straße 268 in einfachen
verhältnissen aufgewachsen ist
[Musik]
so speziell ist kann ich sogar heiraten
das letzte mal bin ich vorausgesagt
bisher hatte ich wieder da bin ich
emotional ich soviel ufer vor
die fünfköpfige familie wohnte in einer
kleinen vierzimmerwohnung auf engstem
raum
19 da ist schlaf 10 mexiko ist natürlich
jeden krieg balkon das glück des kleinen
freddy war dass die große welt gleich
nebenan begann im hallenstadion und in
der offenen radrennbahn die flasche
sammeln und der fleischer brachmann
fronten so veranstalten gesehen bin ich
hingegangen und haben wohl bis zu
sammeln und ich werde es auch eine
profitiere
sollen lehrer leisten kann stolz machte
[Musik]
die reaktion seines vaters ernst auf die
manager pläne des sohnes gehören zu
freddy burgas bleibenden erinnerungen an
diese zeit
47 jahre ist das nun her das hat mich
prägt sie stabiler im kopf was
wasserdruck scheitert und im ersten
moment gar nicht so gut gefunden worden
uns gesagt hat als der andere sieht dann
mit special wo mir können passieren dass
es mir ganz klar und deutlich so
dargestellt hat noch heute habe er
manchmal angst dass er sich alles was er
sich erarbeitet hat wieder verlieren
könnte
ich rief sie laut faber war bis vor zur
hartz iv asse damit das ist vollkommen
gerne form kranken nicht nur gern hatte
der zürcher aus dem stadtkreis 12 erfolg
sondern auch oft für seine verdienste
überreichte im stadtrat martin
vollenwyder im letzten jahr die
ehrenmedaille der stadt zürich die
bürger der stadt zürich treuekarte der
irrsinnige karriere gemacht
im bereich unterhaltungs management lang
sein und fredeburger ist eine stadt
zürich mit sinne dann wachsen
seine ersten erfolge feierte der junge
frau die in den 60er jahren mit einer
band namens jimmy hendrix
diese kritik
[Musik]
der ausflug nach hamburg ist für freddy
burger in doppelter hinsicht speziell
sein sohn oliver begleitet ihn auf diese
reise in die vergangenheit
der 25-jährige soll dereinst in die
fußstapfen seines vaters treten
ich bin sehr spontan harry potter krieg
als die welt des gerätes stets und freue
mich auf buntere beobachtet sie die
reaktionen und emotionen
ich freue mich freddy burger war noch
ein stück jünger als sein sohn oliver
heute ist als er hier an der reeperbahn
in schäbigen absteigen mit schimmligen
matratzen nächtigte viele die hier die
geburtsstunde der beat musik miterlebten
waren voller träume und hoffnung nur
wenige haben es die friedeburger zu ruhm
und ehre geschafft
[Musik]
nicht dass ich ins innere bei sucht dann
muss das mit dem ich ja also alles
freddy burger hat seinen ehemaligen
schützling jimmy dann kommt seit
jahrzehnten nicht mehr gesehen
zur überraschung hatte sich ein späßchen
einfallen lassen
[Gelächter]
das muss aufhören
er hofft aber auch auf weitere
weggefährten zu treffen vor allem auf
horst fascher den gründer des star clubs
der damals unbekannten bands eine chance
gab und damit den grundstein zur
weltkarriere der beatles legte
natürlich wieder die macht früher kinder
und da mal lieber um und sagt sie
für dieses und von freunden
von rettet aber nicht
naja da hatten 36 jahre später am abend
genießen vater und sohn den auftritt von
jimi hendrix
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bitte ist auch sie wie berlin oder
[Musik]
hauptdurchschlag ist studierter profi
2011 ahlmann der pepper engagiert wird
für die skala für das firmen für die
jugend das jubiläum ist sich die branche
30 franken pro a big bobby da sämtliche
sachen inbegriffen sind micro media
mieterrechten aufwand für personal und
equipment wo man die erfahrung muss mit
dem ganzen eigene liegt das einfach was
man haben muss ich richtig gezählt
ich hoffe einfach dass jetzt noch ein
bislang wieder gott dass er mir wieder
spaß an der musik wie sie jetzt meinen
kollegen zusammen also noch eine wette
machen
mit keinem anderen künstler arbeitet für
die bürger länger zusammen als mit
rebellion halt also weil er ist so
funktionieren wie raus menschen und das
ist ganz klar aber ich glaube das
prinzip dass man das jetzt so genau
vertrauen hat er martin georgi natürlich
in der muna bislang für seinen
programmen die kameradschaftlichen
entscheidung aber in große ganze kann
jedoch jeder das gemacht was dran und
ich glaube das ist fast keine
spektakulär an der macht sehen will grün
steht die heimischen manager manager für
ihn noch nie gehalten so dass wir einen
kokon freddy burger ist 66 jahre alt er
hat viele dinge sehr früh angepackt auch
im privatleben drei söhne hat er aus
zwei ehen
seine zweite ehe hielt über 20 jahre
66 jahren da fängt das leben mit 66
jahren da hat man spaß daran
heute ist er mit einer frau zusammen die
ihr über die arbeit kennengelernt hat
und die im eigenen unternehmen die
kommunikationsabteilung führt bei uns
ist liebe mit dem spiel das in ihrem
fall wörtlich kein ja mach ich werde
meine sind die trierer halbjahr war das
nur für euch beide mutige schritt sie
anno dazumal mannschaftlich so viel
länger mitten und erkannt wo dann kommen
wir nur freundschaftsspiele sich und
sieht uns in retz das paar mitunter
[Musik]
im august dieses jahres ist es ebenfalls
eine herzensangelegenheit die
friedeburger nach liverpool führt die
stadt feiert 50 jahre beatles
[Musik]
[Applaus]
rad
ja
das macht sich einige darüber will ich
denke das ist so super dass manche
wirklich so mutig sind herausstellte
dass ich glaube das braucht das
vertrauen das man das macht das hat mich
immer unterstützt
wo habe ich auf der welt an und sieben
den ersten vertrag den fredeburger
aufsetzte war jener mit dem sortieren
bei
es wäre wohl ich das irgendwie
realisieren magische begriffen dass ich
es wirklich begriffen sie aber das für
uns natürlich weit weg sie die hand zwar
schon eher gemacht aber als die beatles
oder wähle auch andere beispiele wo
beatles kosmetischen betrieb sind sie
sind wieder da die so verwischen
[Musik]
das war vor mehr als 40 jahren heute
spielen die sauterel am festival zu
ehren der großen vorbilder live in
liverpool auf freddy burger erlebt mit
wie seine ehemalige band auftritt als
einzige band an diesem nachmittag dürfen
die männer um toni vescoli da eine
zugabe spielen
[Musik]
der winter besucht zürich und mit ihm
kommt die nachricht dass udo jürgens am
tag vor seinem konzert erkrankt sein
schwedens eg frank knauer magen
darmgrippe und wissen der prinz trennte
als bürger im hallenstadion eintrifft
ist jedoch klar dass udo jürgens heute
vor ausverkauften rängen wird auftreten
können
das sohn oliver begleitet die tournee
leitung in ein paar jahren soll er die
firma des vaters übernehmen rückzug
wissenschaft bevor
das war zum glück nur 24 soll steckt
zehn jahre noch will freddy burger
augenblicke wie diese vor einem konzert
genießen
dazu gehört auch die erleichterung wenn
der künstler gesund und mit hund auf der
bühne erscheint telefonierte mit schlafe
vorgestern
der arzt hatte medikamente habe hunt 2
an der infusion gestern wurden da haben
wir gesagt readymix wieder gut eine
halbe stunde vor konzertbeginn
das hallenstadion fühlt sich auch
bulgers jüngster sohn stefan ist im
publikum 9000 menschen sind gekommen um
udo jürgens zu sehen
erneut ist es eine tournee der rekorde
die konzerte des 78 jährigen sind fast
überall nahezu ausverkauft
[Musik]
sitzt
si
[Musik]
die kleine schweiz
nach drei stunden ist es wieder einmal
vollbracht
der künstler lässt sich vorne im
scheinwerferlicht im weißen bademantel
feiern
er darf das für die bürger genießt
derweil den applaus der auch ein
bisschen seiner ist im halbdunkel hinter
der bühne so weit hat es der kleine bub
von nebenan also geschafft seit er hier
im hallenstadion vor vielen jahren damit
begonnen hat band flaschen zusammen
[Musik]